Nick Cannon confirms he has another baby
on the way you know better than me
the 36 year old America's Got Talent
host was guest on power 105 1's
Breakfast Club on Thursday where he got
super candid about his personal life
absolute Nick first played coy when the
host asked him outright about the rumors
his ex-girlfriend ringing Bell is
pregnant with his child to have a baby
on the way or something I got a song
with k.michelle called baby on the way
but he later spilled the beans got a
baby on the way so God said be fruitful
and multiply go I'm doing the Lord's
work out here and Nick also got candid
about his ex-wife Mariah Carey's messy
breakup with billionaire James Packer I
thought they was working it out I see us
are you saying you just really just like
we do yeah you don't you don't tell you
anything I don't I'm gonna need to know
basis wait long as my kids are good I
see you I don't weekend's we had Chuckie
Cheese we flying kites I want to know
none of that other stuff
you